[Musique]
il n'est sans doute pas mauvais d'entrer
dans le drame algérien par l'algérie
elle-même un coup d'oeil sur alger qui
n'était voici 130 ans qu'une bourgade
moyenâgeuse donc tout de suite le ton
des transformations accompli alger est
devenue aujourd'hui une de ses grandes
cités modernes où s'alignent des
bâtiments dignes de n'importe quelle
capitale
ces constructions majestueuse voisinent
avec les créations des temps passés
qu'une sagesse prévoyante a tenu à
conserver intact près de quatre cent
mille habitants y vivent et alger aussi
bien par sa situation que par son
activité se classe au premier plan de
l'avenir méditerranée cette alger
s'ouvre sur une algérie transformé par
130 ans d'aménagement un outillage
moderne où les grands barrages et les
travaux d'irrigation o'cain la première
place on fertilise et d'une immense
espace où naguère s'étendait le désert
[Musique]
la vigne et le blé congé de leur
production à 2 au quotient de rendement
pendant que le cheptel s'est décuplée on
parle aujourd'hui de pétrole en certains
endroits où les forages se sont avérés
prometteurs d'un nouvel avenir et
l'animation de ces ports manifeste que
l'algérie n'occupe pas une mauvaise
place dans le système économique
méditerranéen
tout cela est l'oeuvre d'un siècle
français depuis deux ans certains
essaient de compromettre les fruits de
cet effort et son avenir mais la fièvre
s'est emparée de l'algérie depuis deux
ans les attentats ne cesse à un endroit
que pour reprendre à un autre alimenté
par les propagandes mensongères et les
méthodes de terreur et rupture de
communication ne se comptent pas plus
que les poteaux arrachés et les
sabotages de voies ferrées
[Musique]
chaque mois qui passe apporte la
nouvelle d'un déraillement souvent
meurtriers des gaz est victime
victimes et dégâts trafic interrompu
difficultés de transport insécurité des
liaisons
sur les grandes routes aussi
l'insécurité règne il n'est pas rare de
trouver les arbres abattus en travers du
chemin
mais la terreur à des formes plus
sombres la nuit des bandes armés
attaquent les fermes isolées au matin on
découvre des murs noircis des toitures
effondrées sur l'air de la cour les
animaux de l'établissent t'égorger les
terroristes n'ont pas voulu qu'une seule
vie même animal subsista de ce qui avait
été un foyer heureux et une entreprise
prospère
on se souvient encore de cette nuit
tragique ou plusieurs fermes des
environs de palestro furent assaillis
leurs habitants martyriser les
survivants ne purent que mimer les
gestes de l'attak lincendie avait
complété le crime
ce jour là on avait dénombré plusieurs
cadavres pour chaque attentes
parmi eux il y avait des femmes et il y
avait des enfants
les bandits avaient tous tués sans
distinction et parfois avec des
raffinements qui pouvait s'appeler
sauvagerie ou sadisme chaque jour depuis
deux ans les drames de ce genre ce
succès c'est sur la route
un autocar attaquer c'est passager a
battu
[Musique]
c'est l'attentât dans un village c'est
l'attaqué d'une maison isolée
[Musique]
c'est toujours des morts et des blessés
l'hélicoptère emporte vers l'hôpital
ceux qui respectent encore et l'on
retrouve à quelques distances
les cadavres de ce camp menèrent les
fellaghas
[Musique]
oh
et
il faut plonger jusqu'au fond de
l'horaire jeter un regard sur ces restes
d'effroyables qu'on n'ose pas découvrir
tout à fait sûr c'est cher arraché à
coups de serpe ou à coups de rasoir sur
ces cadavres dépecés comme de la viande
de boucherie l'horreur ici arrête les
mots dans la gorge
[Musique]
mieux vous refermez les cercueils sur
leur contenu qui n'a plus de nom
accompagné ces convois qui tout le long
de deux années n'ont pas cessé de suivre
la route des cimetières en 1956
seulement on n'a pas compté moins de 10
700 victimes musulmans ou européens
hommes et femmes et enfants regardons
passer ces convois celui du caïd el
hassar l'aïd du doigt à ça il en aura ni
tués dans une embuscade
peut-on dire que son douar faisait cause
commune avec ces assassins et sept
autres convois celui d'un français
il était maire de sa ville une vie de
travail et de dévouement consacré aux
deux communautés européennes et
musulmane il paie de sa vie son
attachement à la chose publique
regardons surtout les 54 cercueil de
philippe vive la tuerie du 20 août 1955
a endeuillé toute la ville cinquante
quatre corps côte à côte une population
en deuil comment fermer les yeux sur ces
visages
usé par les larmes ces silhouettes brisé
deux sanglots est cependant en dépit de
ces drames la vie algérienne ne s'est
pas arrêtée comme elle aurait pu comme
certains l'auraient voulu
les marchés de l'intérieur ont gardé
leur animation pittoresque les villes et
les bourgs ont conservé leurs allées et
venues habituel ce qu'une arme était
venu faire ici ce n'est pas la
reconquête comme une habile propagande
veulent faire croire
elle est venue pour assurer la
continuation de la vie algérienne et la
sauvegarde de groupes humains qui vivent
ensemble sur cette terre depuis cinq
générations
en dépit de toutes les menaces et de
tous les attentats les terres ont été
cultivés et la récolte de l'année avec
ses 25 millions de quintaux dépasse même
en importance celle des années
précédentes
l'armée cette fameuse armée qu'on dit
occupé à des représailles sans scrupule
à continuer les travaux entrepris
on la voit jouant le rôle d'ingénieurs
et d'architectes
dirigés ou accomplir les travaux qui
ouvrent une route créer un barrage de
retenue
un déversoir
pour avoir quitté ses armes pour bâtir à
la place d'un assemblage de cahutes un
îlot d'habitations scène est commode
[Musique]
cette armée dit de répression partout et
les a ouverts ces ambulances essaient
pharmacie à tout venant
combien de villages et douars et part
dans les campagnes ont pu être soignées
secours eu grâce au dévouement des
médecins et des infirmiers militaires
l'armée a continué le programme de santé
suivi depuis un siècle et qui a fait en
jugulant la maladie et la mortalité
tripler la population de l'algérie en un
siècle le trachome la tuberculose le
paludisme ont perdu leur virulence la
mortalité infantile a baissé de 70%
et l'armée continuent de maintenir ce
qui a été dans ce pays un bulletin de
santé tels que l'on connaisse aucun des
peuples orientaux qui s'arrogent le
droit de juger la france à travers le
drame algérien
comme il s'est fait architectes
ingénieurs infirmiers le soldat s'est
fait d'instituteurs dans les écoles
désertées il a pris la place du maître
victimes de la persécution
il a rouvert aux enfants les portes de
l'école on les a vus ces garçons
reprendre sous l'uniforme la classe
abandonné et dans ces pays où la
première forme de la civilisation
l'école était menacée de disparaître
l'école a pu se maintenir grâce à ces
farouches guerriers puisque la présence
de cette arme n'est supprimer toute
possibilité d'une révolte ouverte le
terrorisme près une forme méthodique il
fallait continuer à assurer le désordre
en algérie deux nouveaux cadavres marque
ce changement d'orientation où cette
fois le parti communiste algérien
inféodés à l'étranger a pris la place
d'organisateurs la bombe de l' usine à
gaz d'alger devait en être la preuve
directe le 16 novembre 1956 la police
découvre est une bombe à retardement
dans un local de l'usiné à gaz du hamma
son explosion aurait dû causer de gros
dégâts
on arrêta un militant communiste fernand
yveton qui avait été chargé de la place
et il apparaissait que le parti
communiste algérien semblait prendre
maintenant une part majeure dans
l'organisation du terrorisme un contrôle
sévère de la navigation aérienne au
dessus du territoire avait permis de se
saisir de ce un chef rebelle dont
benbella benbella mohamed khider ait
ahmed boudiaf et lacheref avait été pris
alors qu'il partait pour tunis avec la
suite d'une haute personnalité il est
inutile d'épiloguer ainsi sa firme
l'immixion étrangères s'affirme surtout
par l'aide apportée par les pays voisins
à la frontière tunisienne
on a fait prisonnier dans un commando un
ouvrier musulman de lyon cueilli à son
arrivée à tunis par la police et remis
par elle à une organisation de hors la
loi
on a saisi à plusieurs reprises des
convois d'armes de toutes sortes
[Musique]
dans le sud aux lisières du désert les
patrouilles méharistes son chargé
d'exercer une surveillance de tous les
instants sur cette frontière éminemment
perméable où tous les trafics peuvent se
donner libre cours
[Musique]
à la frontière algéro-marocaine même
problème grâce à des complaisances
vraiment trop excessive des convois
d'armes passent on a même dû protéger la
frontière par une surveillance très
spéciale avec réseau de barbelés et
patrouilles aériennes l'importation
d'armes se fait là sur une grande
échelle
[Applaudissements]
un exemple suffira à la date du 20
décembre 1956 une caravane était
intercepté dans la région de tchita
maghnia un convoi transportant une
grosse quantité d'armes de toutes sortes
ou les mitrailleuses et les mortiers
étaient nombreux ces armes de
nationalités diverses empruntait pour
parvenir en algérie la route d'une
région voisine dont l'assistance aux
hors la loi s'avère ainsi notoire est
déclarée
[Musique]
sûr mais également l'utilité des
patrouilles s'est révélé efficace
[Musique]
c'est ainsi qu'en octobre
on a saisi et a résonné à la limite des
eaux algéro-marocaine un bateau pirate
qui sous des noms différents
atos ou saint-brieuc wells a porté hors
la loi une cargaison considérable et son
équipage a parlé
[Musique]
c'est 70 tonnes d'armes d'une valeur de
plus de 2 milliards de francs étaient
destinés aux rebelles
cette cargaison composée d'armes du
dernier modèle comportait plus de 2000
fusil des mitrailleuses lourdes et 75
mortier elle avait été chargée dans un
port égyptien d'alexandrie
par des militaires égyptiens cargaison
et aveu met directement en cause le
gouvernement du colonel nasser dont la
parole de soldat donnés à monsieur
christian pineau sur la non-ingérence de
l'egypte en algérie reçoit là un violent
démenti car il éclate aujourd'hui à tous
les yeux même les plus aveugles et où
les moins avertis que l'egypte en dépit
de tous les engagements et de toutes les
déclarations alimentent la révolte
algérienne une page secrète de la
rébellion algérienne s'est ainsi ouverte
au grand jour elle manifeste hautement
aussi bien que les convois venue par la
tunisie et le maroc aussi bien que la
tension marquée à ben bella la
participation de l'étranger à une
affaire purement français
mais il faut aussi dans ce regard
circulaire fait allusion à d'autres
faits c'en est un car le serbe el adjouz
chef d'une bande de l'aurès se soit
rendu de son propre mouvement est lancé
un appel à la reddition adjoul a compris
il ne faut pas oublier ces foules qui
viennent chercher auprès des français
une sauvegarde qui leur assurera la
liberté du travail dans le pays qui
menacerait d'être la 3d factions et du
désordre continuelle comme il l'était
autrefois le jour où la france ni
remplirait pas sa mission
l'algérie est un problème aujourd'hui
mais un problème français un problème
français qui exige une solution
française
[Musique]